Greg Hunter Biden scandal is now
spreading to other parts of his father's
Administration Secretary of State
Anthony blinken is denying any role in
discrediting the laptop story after it
was revealed that Lincoln was the
impetus behind that Infamous letter
signed by 51 Intel officers who called
it Russian interference
I want to ask about the letter that was
written concerning Hunter Biden's laptop
that said it was you know Russian
disinformation can you explain what your
role was in that and if you incentivized
it with regard to uh to that letter
I didn't wasn't my idea didn't ask for
it didn't solicit it and I think the
testimony
that the former deputy director of the
CIA Mike Morrell put forward confirms
that and here's a blast from the past
Obama's former Attorney General Eric
Holder is weighing in on the hunter
investigation despite an IRS
whistleblower alleging that the first
son is getting special treatment and FBI
agents complaining the investigation is
taking too long holder says there's
actually nothing to see here
what's taking so long in your view I
don't know you know what's going on in
terms of the investigation but I'm
confident that it's being conducted in
an appropriate way
um you know the person who was handling
the case who is uh the chief
investigator is a a former is a U.S
attorney Who was appointed by the former
president people here in Washington D.C
tend to keep their hands off of those
cases and allow the people in the field
politically sensitive cases in the field
uh to Simply you know run their course
Jesse you take either one
um the Anthony blinken answer or our
friend Eric Holder so Morel is CIA and
he says that he had nothing to do with
the letter and then he went back and
changed his testimony and said actually
Lincoln told me to have the letter done
and then blinken says oh I didn't have
anything to do with anything it's more
like this it was like hey that looks
like Russian disinformation to me
doesn't it to you and then it's like a
wink wink so it's like a he said he said
with a bunch of spies and liars and
everybody denies it all
listen Blanket's never going to get
asked about this again so he's done and
they'll just run out the clock with it
but you know this that the CIA and the
FBI installed a corrupt old man into the
White House and now they control him
they control his son they control him
Biden admitted the other day he just
takes orders and that's what he does
what is the is the FBI on this year have
they investigated
both candidates in the last three
elections in 2016 and 2020 and 2024 both
sides under investigation by the CIA and
the FBI that's how you know this whole
thing is being controlled behind the
scenes I was thinking about this the
other day Dana how did Barack Obama pick
Brennan
remember Brennan he was Bush's guy that
was all into waterboarding and Obama
said he was against waterboarding it was
torture how did he end up being his
Intel guy and then how did Burns
end up being Joe Biden's CIA director
after he was paddling around with
Jeffrey Epstein how do these things
happen you're never going to find out
because you know the CIA and the FBI
control everything behind the scenes and
we we can't put up with it anymore do
you have one of those boards up in your
office has like the red string like a
clearance
it goes right to the top Jesse who's the
top I don't know neither do I yeah all
right it's not Joe yes over to you Greg
well you know what I think blinking is
guilty as Sin but it doesn't matter
because he probably doesn't have
anything written down like who writes
this stuff down him it's spy versus spy
remember that little cartoon so they
could they could say each other all they
want and it doesn't matter because you
know you know I doubt there's you I
doubt you're gonna find a Post-It note
that says hey Morel create a hoax create
a Russian disinfo hoax that might you
know that might be unprovable blah blah
blah blah No One's Gonna write that down
so I do like Lincoln's what did he say
in this interview that he goes I don't
do politics
yeah it's just a direct Secretary of
State yeah but I don't do policy so what
is what does he do with Secretary of
State is he telling all of us that they
do nothing but maybe garden and
needlepoint because that's really that's
quite a revelation I don't know what did
you think of either of those especially
I'm curious about what Eric Holder said
that everything's going along a pace
yeah you know what I love when Eric
Holder says basically everything is fine
nothing to see here I say to myself how
do you know
you know there's nothing to see here and
don't give me this everything is okay
and by the way weren't you held in
content by Congress for the Fast and
Furious Eric Holder aren't you Obama's
Wing man that you do whatever he says
but aside from all that let's talk about
the fact that he says the United States
Attorney investigating Hunter Biden was
appointed by by Donald Trump here's the
problem the grand jury investigated
Hunter Biden for five years that means
when he says we allow the people in the
field to do their own investigation and
we don't interfere well they finish
their investigation it's been five years
so now it's back in your lap Arrow Eric
Holder it's back in your lap because
they can't do anything now without the
permission of the Attorney General or
the dag the deputy attorney general
because he's a public official so liar
liar you pants on fire they can't do
anything unless Merrick Garland approves
it can I ask you one thing about the
hunter Biden uh yesterday in Arkansas
there's going to be another court
appearance on May 12th and then I guess
it actually is going to go to some
decision making this summer right before
you get into the primary season in 2024.
right and I think my sense is that
they're going to work it out because the
Biden family and Joe Biden is a
candidate cannot afford all this
information coming out by the way I
can't imagine talk about a board with a
lot of red strings how many people are
getting money who don't want to be
mentioned I mean there are people I
remember it was one of the heads of the
FBI who gave Joe Biden a hundred
thousand dollars so that he could invest
with him in another country Louis free
everybody's involved in this it's just
like you say it's an incestuous One hand
washes the other group do you have a
board with red string
No I gave it up after the Mueller report
okay
um I think that Mike morale should sit
again
for the committee to Claire to at least
con or really put out a written
statement whatever it is because if
Anthony bliggin is directly
contradicting his testimony it was
interesting to me and I by the way I
thought that Benjamin Hall did a
wonderful job doing the interview and
it's great to see him back yeah um on
the air
but
Lincoln says and and you'll see that
this confirms what Morel said but that
doesn't confirm what Morel says it runs
in contradiction to what Morel said so I
think that we should hear from Morel
again if we have to hear from Lincoln
again that's fine I think that as many
people who are related to this or could
be related to it should be on the record
talking about it and then we'll have a
fair process hopefully and get to the
bottom of it on all of your red lines
um to the point about Eric Holder saying
you know there's nothing there
um he probably has access to more than
we have it does seem like he's going out
on a bit of a limb saying that though it
was just in a cable news interview but
I'll remind everyone because we kind of
forget and we think of the Obama Biden
Administration as kind of you know two
hands of one person but they're really
not the Biden people are Biden's people
and the Obama people there aren't that
many Crossovers and there was a lot of
or what do you say no love lost between
them and there's a lot of feelings that
Biden isn't necessarily living up to the
Obama I'm a legacy is you know in 2016
they ended up losing obviously it was
Hillary's race but Biden could have
gotten in he arguably would have won and
then quite in perspective they're like
oh yeah well look at all that we have
accomplished you're going to see a lot
of that so that isn't as merry as it
seems all the time no I say something
okay Senator Ron Johnson says that
blinken said he never emailed Hunter
Biden except they have the laptop where
he emails Hunter Biden so I don't know
that you need to put anyone under oath
anymore that's a lie right there 18 USC
one zero zero one boom one zero zero one
I got that red thread right up next The
Godfather of AI out with a startling
warning that the tech will do a Bad
Thing hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now